hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
this is the horror games collection a
collection of horror games because this
is a video about scary games
which means that you can expect the
following
spooky sounds strange knocking on your
doors
breathing right behind your ears and of
course
something coming to claim you in the
middle of this video
at some random point you will be taken
enjoy the video
we are starting off with vainless
property which is apparently
also inspired by junji ito i say also
because
in a previous three scary games i played
a game that was inspired by june deito
and this is the the horror games
collection from triality or something
like that
also apparently epilepsy warning my
parents are finally gone for this
weekend
and it's getting pretty late i should
probably go to bed but i have to turn
off the lights first
um
uh
i think maybe you have some more
problems besides just the lights being
on
um oh
what did you take man oh
hi oh
yeah okay this is super weird but i love
it
i love it also i don't know why my voice
is a little deeper i've got like some
stuff in my throat
now i'm just kind of rolling with it is
that a face actually
i don't even need to ask that that is
most assuredly a face
actually now that i'm thinking about is
that just a body no that's just a face
in the hill
okay that's weird okay
strange well i can't leave
so guess i'm stuck here or i'm gonna go
to bed
before my parents come and be mad at me
for not
doing what i'm supposed to do oh yeah
here we go
oh yeah that's a little weird
peek-a-boo
i guess we just don't go in that room
okay
i guess that room is just a no-no room
and i don't ever need to worry about it
now i can finally get some rest can i
oh oh
[Music]
no oh no
oh i hate that one second
i'll be right there
hello hi
oh
well that was delightful um i'm gonna go
to bed now
what
[Music]
i'm just gonna go to bed this
i don't remember there being a door here
oh no that was the door to the other one
okay i'm just gonna go to bed now oh
hey whoo huh
my mouse got inverted what happened
[Music]
why did my mouse get inverted i don't
like this one bit i need something to
defend myself
i don't even know what just happened i'm
gonna turn on the lights again
um i don't know what i could defend
myself with
maybe a knife from the kitchen i guess
oh
that's what happened oh no
i'm assuming that means that they just
threw a rock and not that they're in the
house now
that would be problematic that'd be very
problematic
i'm assuming i need to go to the kitchen
and i need to get a knife
or i'm gonna do exactly that
hey don't big don't
i've got it slice
911 anybody
whatever the japanese equivalent of it
is
okay i mean should i go
don't even think about it i'll
kill you oh my god what is that
huh
uh you can't get okay
[Music]
yeah but it looks like i brought a knife
to a knife fight but i don't even know
what's going on with your
louis let me stay right here and we can
become one
help me grow
what i don't know the inspiration for
this one from junejito
well that was a little bizarre not 100
sure what happened there
not 100 sure what's going on anyway
pretty good i love the style i really
did love this style it was so unnerving
just like the red jagged lines
everywhere it was terrible
anyway moving on this
is maybe another life another game in
the triality horror games collection
oh oh that was cool
i mean i'm not happy about where i am
but that was i'm fast
oh i'm
what hi what what
what what what am i look what
water what what are you what
what
huh what i'm i'm very confused
right off the bat i'm oh
okay am i stepping inside this
no no
no you don't oh you're not doing any
mind-bending physics things to me are
you
oh you are not oh you are 100 not
okay oh
well i didn't even get a choice to
rotate the wheel there it just kind of
did it
okay ah
oh weird what is this supposed to be
oh
okay all right
weird funky okay
and then i'm on the other side which is
good
also why is any of this some kind of
portal ass
testing
oh ho ho ho
hi oh hi oh hi
oh hi oh hi
oh hi wally
[Music]
wally
okay well you didn't grab anything
you were just pantomiming
oh why hello
oh god hi hello
my name is markiplier i have a podcast
called distractible oh
[Applause]
ah please don't
oh god hi
well i've been squooshed or grabbed
oh just grabbed not squooshed
[Music]
okay
it's like the opening of lord of war
and just the bullet being tossed through
the factory
okay
no i can't run any faster
[Music]
i thought i was fast before but
apparently
oh you dick oh you dick
[Music]
well that hurt i want to look at that
you're dead that that's okay
no really it's part of the game to die
you did nothing wrong you'll be
reborn let's see your new self
is 32 years old lives in ireland
and your job is stand
up comedian oh you first chose about to
start
come on give it your best don't waste
another life
uh but uh type what you want to say and
enter to save um ah
let's always get some okay all right
oh duh
okay um
uh oh that killed him
oh
[Music]
no
hi so this is the opening of the hunger
games i think it's going to go
freaking imax yeah
oh am i free i think i might have wasted
that life a little bit
know i know i know i know
i know i don't know okay spongebob i
know yeah
[Music]
hello
oh cool tom branch
interesting you know not a terrifying
experience
oh funky hi
uh hey don't choke me don't do it ah
you're coming
uh hilarious entry menu oh
ah i get you okay yeah not a truly like
scary experience but i can definitely
see what they were trying to do there
in terms of like the experimental
mechanics but a lot of the mechanics
just seemed like a showpiece as opposed
to actually being like an interesting
part of the game however
i did like the styling of the ambiance
was very good and left me thinking that
there was
dangers looking around every corner
which apparently there weren't it was
just a giant claw
and then a crowd of people which is
terrifying
the game psychopath was recently called
4d horror it was a horror riddle game
based on the house of a friend of mine
so we actually had to look around for
puzzles i hid in his real house to
complete a riddle
now there's been a massive update to
make this completely different game as
it used to be
thank you for downloading the three
games three weeks three dudes horror
game edition
okay psychopath made by gregorious
kissing
okay
oh
okay oh
[Music]
hi hello oh
there's code okay
e oh you've got mail hey it's me don't
remember well it doesn't matter anyway
you've got to get out of here asap
you've been kidnapped by a psychopath
i've sent you some codes on your actual
computer for the first door
you can find these codes in the really
awesome and sick horror games collection
triality games folder
i do not remember which code was the
right one but there's a quote which tell
me to remember it it goes
the root of educations are bitter but
the fruit
is sweet now who would have said that if
you were lazy or it is not working
properly then click on this folder
what what the roots of education are
bitter but the fruit is sweet
mama code i don't think michael jackson
said that i don't think bunny fufu
i don't think the bibble william
shakespeare these
i don't know i'm not a hundred percent
sure
probably like aristotle's or something
like that i don't know
uh interesting
clearly this is something okay what was
the code for
you've got mail uh
loki loki
oh oh there we go oh hey
hi hi oh hi hi there oh
well that's less fun um
what is that kmtr
does that mean for this one kmtr kmtr
oh got that one okay good codes are good
codes are good lots of soda okay
not sure what that's about oh here we go
there's something over here
oh here we go okay
uh-huh okay
i do not like the slapping
okay rtn rtn
rtn it is
hello who's up here
oh hi hello how are you
hey stop that
is this also what your friend had to
deal with okay oh
okay thanks for that
okay okay um rtn
no not that one okay okay so what i
gotta do is uh sneak by
i think otherwise he's going to get me
i'm gonna go for it oh good go
go just you dressed up like that in your
friend's room
okay there's something else here it's
just meatballs that's what
here meatballs that i'm throwing so hard
they're going on the wall
okay um wow i don't know what this is
f-g-t-o-o-o-f-o-g-o-t-e
what f-g-t-o-o-e-r-t-n
maybe it's all one big combo
g-t-o-o-e-r-t-n
no no oh what if it was laterally
okay so f o r
uh g-o-t oh
forgotten ah wait
what but but i did it right didn't i
just do it
but it didn't open but it what it what
what is it bugged or something
did it get bugged i'm going for it
oh i can go up okay maybe this is what i
was supposed to do
high eyeball
[Music]
uh-huh okay oh good good good
what duma
[Music]
well that's the that's the one from the
other game i see that
how about this it's not letting it's
it's stuck
it's like stuck in there why why have
you done this
oh why have you done this it's like
bugged ah damn it ah god damn it
all right i know what it is though
okay but that didn't do anything it went
bading
i don't remember what that one was but
it didn't do anything i think this one
might be a little bit bugged
that was the three games in that
however i'm gonna go ahead and say
little underwhelmed
didn't get enough of a punch of a scare
i didn't really get the
wallop of the scares that i was looking
for there's some promise in the games
that they had they were more
experimental but also
i need to get some wampage up in here so
i'm gonna play one more game here
and this one is called inside the dark
which might just be a typical scary
gamer it might be bad i have no idea
that's the thing about these indie games
i don't really know how they're gonna
turn out
not to say those games were bad i'm not
saying that at all i just want some
extra
lumpage in this video ever since that
day
i've kept wandering in the dark
oh i might be in the dark door won't
open
i found myself in the back rooms once
again
seems like i always come back here no
matter where i go
[Music]
is this my home can't get in
no not my home i don't even know what
this place is
the layout is very weird with its
strange upper hallway that leads to
nothingness
at least i have my flashlight
that's fine hello
anybody here this room
feels strangely familiar the weird
time-out chair in the corner
where i used to spend most of my days
because i was such a bad bad boy
it's locked
all right well i guess it was oddly
familiar for no reason
guess i'll go downstairs then hi weirdly
brightly lit
room dot dot dot
got nothing to say about that one i
don't
won't open all right i'll go back
upstairs then
it's locked all right upstairs it is
there must be something else here that i
missed because if that's locked
maybe i could sit down in the chair yeah
okay okay
a key grandma
who knocked down grandmama uh oh
i'm watching you yeah from the timeout
corner yeah i bet
oh hi
well i don't have time to wait excuse me
not going to be creeped out by that
not at all it's locked and the key don't
fit do it
hey good why does the distance look
blood red
i don't appreciate that very much
oh that's why why why why why
why well i just answered the question i
guess
i'll take a seat yes i guess i will take
a seat
yeah i'll just sit here yeah this is
good i like to sit in a room
in the middle looking out the open door
at the long hallway
no you wouldn't you wouldn't do that to
me
you wouldn't do that no don't even think
about that
are you coming here
uh-huh yeah sure okay
yeah i'm just gonna believe that i'm in
a new place yeah absolutely yeah just
give me a key
you know when i asked for a little more
pie lunch
how did i end up here i remember
grabbing that key
yeah when i asked for more punch i
didn't ask for cheap jump scares
although it is a people pleaser
whatever oh it is dark all right let's
go down hallway number
two down to the basement okay yeah let's
do that
yeah hey what's going on down here is
this a party basement
this my neighbor's unfinished basement
it won't open
face your fear to move on okay
[Laughter]
okay i'll face my fear you rogue
come at me another seat
i get to sit and watch again
well apparently not okay i'll go back
yeah back down the hallway that's
definitely
perfectly normal
locked
uh oh
hi okay
don't trust that okay
don't trust it blocked
right definitely locked
definitely not down here with some kind
of a ghost
didn't expect that to open
my flashlight doesn't seem to be very
bright here
oh no oh no
oh hey hi hello i'm here now
okay did i face my fear did that count
that counted apparently oh floating key
yeah okay i remember there being a door
that said dot dot dot on it
i remember that distinctly so i'm going
to go to that door
and it's going to all be okay i'm going
to go home
and i'm going to have a great day
i might have been right the myth was
true
the legend is true it's never going to
end
why i've made my decision
what decision cody larkin
hey cody that was good you know you had
one cheap jump scare in there but a lot
of the other spooks were pretty damn
spooky
i'm not gonna lie that was pretty good
so that was three scary games thank you
did we check off the list of all the
expectations of things that you could
know
were going to happen in this video you
definitely felt the breathing down your
neck
you definitely heard the strange
footsteps approaching you from behind
you definitely felt a hand being placed
on your shoulder
and then someone leaning in to whisper
into your ear
there's one more box that needs to be
checked
someone will watch you when you sleep
take care and as always
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign